okay i'm finally in israel
of course to understand today's israel
and the surrounding territories
you have to understand its history this
should only take a minute
by 1300 bc settlers had created the
kingdoms of israel and judah who were
conquered by the babylonians who were
conquered by the greeks were conquered
by the romans were conquered by the
byzantines were conquered by the arabs
who were conquered by the crusaders who
were conquered by the ottomans who were
conquered by the british who helped the
dream of a jewish homeland and were
supplanted by jewish refugees fleeing
from nazis who were given an insane map
for two new countries by the united
nations followed by the declaration of
the state of israel which led to a war
with arab nations which led to thousands
of refugees
a crisis with egypt another war with
arabs an occupation terrorism yasser
arafat another war with arabs usa to
israel a settlement policy a peace
treaty a war with lebanon a palestinian
uprising a proposed peace treaty an
assassination another palestinian
uprising another war with lebanon more
settlements more terrorism a separation
wall surging economic growth negative
economic growth hamas and the pla versus
israel hamas versus the pla israeli jews
versus american jews israeli orthodox
jews versus israeli conservative jews
versus israeli reformed jews jewish and
arab men against jewish narrative women
more settlements far raphaeli the
israeli gaza conflict israel hating
obama israel loving trump israelis and
palestinians confused by jared kushner
three of the holiest sites in the world
built on top of each other plus drews
vetoes bahanes and one buddhist
all setting the table for a visit by me
conan o'brien
my mission to try and make some people
laugh and in the process
alienate everyone
i thought i'd start my trip by hitting
the streets of tel aviv and meeting new
friends
hey guys how are you shalom shalom
shalom
you are israelis yes okay uh first of
all how's my
accent shabbat shalom
what is the attitude of israelis about
donald trump what do you guys think
about donald trump
it's a big show for us a big show did
you know that uh
the president's son-in-law is working
very hard on making a peace plan
of course jared kushner yeah jared
kushner has been studying very hard
the issue of middle east peace we found
this book in his hotel room
i think that uh he read two pages
and then uh he got confused and he went
home do you get this a lot of people say
you look kind of like tom cruise yeah do
you get that
you get that all right okay do me a
favor look into that camera
and say you had me at shalom
fantastic good ah nice
you are uh the coolest looking couple
i've seen today you are so what were you
doing you're high typing each other
very modest people i suppose how long
have you been together
seven months seven months and when you
saw him the first time
when he was trying to sell you weed away
let's say he didn't exist no offense but
let's say he wasn't in the picture
and you saw me walking down the street
would you be attracted
well i'm talking to handsome israeli man
number 3652 of the day
what is it with you people it's the best
looking people i've seen anywhere
we've met before how have we met well i
think
october 2003 i was with how do you know
the date
because because it was taped on nbc oh
you came to my show yeah
you said to the camera there's a big
delegation here from israel but uh
there's a delegation here from israel
i'd like to acknowledge
were people laughing was it a good show
of course it's the conan show
no but he told us to laugh i love this
guy
never science those are called no we
have applause signs we've never had a
laugh now sign that's just not true
there's no such thing as a laugh now
sign if there was i'd be huge
i'd be using it now
[Applause]
how you doing you guys just cruising the
neighborhood
yeah i'll take a picture with you guys
all right let's do it you want to have a
selfie with me
thank you all right hey nice to meet you
look at this guy
look at him jacked this guy's jacked
what do you think could you get me in
shape
for sure we're talking about our
weightlifting program
uh these people are getting really mad i
should let them go before i started
internationally sorry i apologize i'm
sorry i'm very sorry
all right let's go let's move on sorry
apologies sorry sorry
sorry it's a moped you could have gone
around oh she's got a nice cookie oh
that's it
oh here we go oh look they she just gave
me
oh no oh no
that went terribly step forward sir i
found the one
israeli male that doesn't work out oh my
god okay you don't all right good
here he is is this your lady right here
yeah are you proud of him for not
working out
um not so much really why he's the one
guy here who refuses to succumb to
this can i also be rude and get a selfie
you're not rude at all look he's shaking
he's so excited no that's just the
weight of the phone he's so weak
can i join you let me remove my shoes
this is very inexpensive airbnb yeah
am i taking too much am i eating too
much oh
you might have had my cake yes of course
you can make all the food thank
i love you country you're still giving
don't
take my cake that's my cake
yeah he's really beautiful you have
israeli beer
sure this is gold star beer yeah you
know if i get paid by gold
star i will split all the money with you
guys let's let's just shoot a quick
commercial for gold star
everyone laugh like i just said
something funny
[Laughter]
oh hi conan o'brien here just having a
nice picnic in tel aviv
and enjoying some gold star beer gold
star it's the beer to have when you're
in tel aviv
on a blanket with people you don't know
after the picnic it was time to hit the
famous beaches of television
shabbat shalom
this is uh no no i want to pay for it
please
i don't like this this is awkward
there's
like 800 israelis behind me watch me
this isn't the flavor i want
check it out this is shy lifeguard here
at tel aviv beach
you've got the best job in the world
whoa
who the hell is this guy why are you
wearing it sir why are you wearing a
sweater at the beach
oh my god look at that oh lord there's
i'm finding things in here you can hang
your sunglasses in here right you just
put them in and they hang right
oh my god that's crazy
attention attention this
is conan o'brien
this is an important announcement will
all
israeli men wearing speedos
please leave the area
again all israeli men wearing speedos
no one wants to see your junk also
why is there an elvis impersonator
on the beach in tel aviv
oh no the elvis impersonator is coming
into the lifeguard station
someone please help me i'm scared
he really doesn't look that much like
elvis i think my mother looks more like
elvis than this guy
oh god hello elvis he wants to play me a
song ladies and gentlemen
in love with you
my god
falling in love
[Applause]
[Music]
with